Welcome to the Man of Recaps,
this is Wheel of Time, Season one.
Our story begins in the quaint
little village of Two Rivers,
where we follow a group of five young friends.
There's Rand the Shepherd, Perrin the blacksmith,
and Matt, the degenerate gambler - slash - thief.
Egwene has just come of age
and gotten her classic two Rivers braid.
And just a few years older is Nynaeve,
The village Wisdom,
like the Medicine Woman,
And she's hoping to take Egwene as an apprentice
because they can do a little bit of magic.
But tonight, the Two Rivers gets a visit
from a woman, Moiraine,
who is a real wizard!
In this world they call it an Aes Sedai
They don’t call it magic,
they call it channeling the One Power,
And the Aes Sedai, the official group of sorceresses,
are respected and feared.
Now this world thinks of time,
not linearly, but as the Wheel of Time,
because it's all about cycles
and reincarnation.
Moiraine is following up on a prophecy
that a youngster from this village
would be a reincarnation of a legendary figure,
The Dragon Reborn.
Problem is all five of them could fit the prophecy,
and it's clear they're all Ta'veren,
people that are super important to fate.
Now tonight’s a big festival at the Two Rivers,
so the peddler Padan Fain comes to town
- more on him later.
And everyone's having a great time
until party crashers arrive!
Oh yeah it's the Trollocs,
these like, Minotaur monsters.
Luckily, there's an Aes Sedai here
to blast them all with some magic.
And Moiraine’s traveling with
her Warder, Lan,
who's a great warrior,
there to watch her back.
A Trolloc busts in to Rand’s house,
but Rand’s dad pulls out his sword from under the bed,
and oh, he's no normal shepherd,
he's a master swordsman!
Perrin grabs an axe, he and his wife
are fighting Trollocs together,
but he goes into a frenzy
and oh, hits her!
No, killed his own wife!
That's traumatizing.
In the end the village is mostly saved,
except Nynaeve, who gets captured.
So Moiraine fills these kids in,
the Dark One is hunting you,
because one of you is the Dragon Reborn,
so they gotta go off on an adventure.
But the Trollocs are hot on their tails,
so they take shelter for a night
in this old ruined city that the Trollocs
won't enter because it's cursed!
Shadar Logoth, the City of Shadow.
Don’t worry, we’ll be fine,
as long as no one touches anything...
But Matt immediately grabs
the obviously cursed dagger.
So the shadow wakes up
and now it's hunting them,
Everyone escapes,
but they're all separated.
Randy and Matt make it to a nearby village
where they befriend the bartender,
but oh, she's here to capture them!
Yes she's a “Dark Friend”, a person who’s
working for The Dark One in hopes of eternal reward.
But there's a Gleeman in town,
a traveling bard,
and this one's Thom Merrilin,
an older rocker type.
And he's a great knife thrower,
saves these guys like,
let's get out of here.
They seek shelter at a nearby farmhouse,
But oh, what's this?
The whole family's been killed!
And maybe it was Matt
with his cursed dagger...
But more likely it was this Nazgul
Voldemort guy called a Fade.
Who are The Dark One’s top lieutenants.
Thom Merrilin stays behind to fight it
so the boys can escape.
Egwene and Perrin are rescued
by a travelling people
called the Tuatha’an,
or more commonly, just the Tinkers.
They follow a pacifist philosophy
called The Way of the Leaf,
because even in self-defense,
violence is always bad.
And this resonates with Perrin
who is still traumatized
by having accidentally
killed his own wife.
But now they have a run in
with the Children of the Light.
We met some before
they’re a religious order,
like the Knights Templar,
committed to doing good.
except the Questioner,
Eamon Valda, who's a real bad dude,
hunting down all Aes Sedai
and like keeping their rings as trophies.
He recognizes Egwene and Perrin
as suspicious characters,
So the Tinkers stand up to defend them,
with no violence...
Which obviously doesn't work
and they're captured.
He thinks Egwene is a secret Aes Sedai,
and indeed, she can channel the one power!
Though she still need some training.
But Perrin has some unexpected powers
of his own
as like a lot of wolves
have been hanging around him lately,
and now his eyes turn yellow,
he gets super strength!
And now a whole pack of wolves
attack the camp and they escape.
Meanwhile, Lan and Moiraine
met up with Nynaeve
who is a huge badass
and managed to escape.
And she doesn't trust anyone,
especially Moiraine,
But Lan convinces her
they're on the same side.
They meet up with some more Aes Sedai,
led by Moiraine’s rival, Liandrin.
And they’ve just captured a man who could channel,
and claimed to be the Dragon Reborn.
Yes the Aes Sedai are all women
because the male half of the One Power
was corrupted by The Dark One,
Any man who channels goes insane.
And so the Red Aes Sedai
hunt down these men and “still” them,
cutting them off from the Power permanently,
but that leaves them
a shell of a human being.
And regarding the Dragon Reborn, it's
uncertain if they're a hero or a villain,
The original Dragon “broke the world.”
Official Aes Sedai policy
is snuff out any potential Dragons,
So Moiraine’s keeping her kids a secret.
But this guy, Logain,
is a real powerful channeler,
Breaks free of his cage and kills
everyone in the room.
But Nynaeve busts in
and she's even stronger,
unleashes a huge blast of magic
to heal everyone!
And the rest of the Aes Sedai
are able to Still this guy.
So our groups all separately
make it to Tar Valon,
the big city in the area and home
to the Aes Sedai’s White Tower.
And Moiraine has to report to the
Aes Sedai’s leader, the Amyrlin Seat
and it's against the rules that Moiraine’s
not telling anyone what she's up to,
so publicly the Amyrlin Seat
has to chastise her.
But privately Moiraine goes to her room,
and these two are old friends -
in fact, they're lovers!
She and Moiraine are the only ones
that know the secret prophecy
that the Aes Sedai aren’t supposed
to fight the Dragon Reborn,
They're supposed to fight *with*
the Dragon Reborn to save the world.
But I guess that info wouldn't be accepted,
so they have to work behind the scenes.
So the Amyrlin Seat pulls out
the unbreakable vow rod,
and banishes Moiriane from the White Tower!
But of course that's exactly what they wanted,
so Moiraine can continue her quest.
The Dark One is escaping his
prison at the Eye of the World,
and so whichever one of you is the Dragon
has to go there and strengthen the seal.
And they can get there real fast
by traveling through the magic door,
But wait, what's this?
Matt is staying behind!
Yes he's been getting
progressively more cursed,
And finally Moiraine was able to get that
curse out of him, put it back in the dagger.
But he’s still not feeling this whole adventure,
so he's just going to stay behind.
Now, “The Ways” are an ancient
magic pathway built by the Ogier,
a race of nature people who
live a long time so move real slow.
This one, Loial, is traveling with them
to help them navigate,
but it's all been corrupted, The Dark One’s
moving his Trollocs through here!
And worse than Trollocs is
Machin Shin, the Black Wind,
that like, uh, whispers all
your worst fears into your head.
But Nynaeve resists it
through the power of stubbornness,
and holds this thing back
so they can all escape.
They're at the fortress city
of Fal Dara, in the borderlands
that guard the world
from The Blight beyond.
Incidentally, this is Lan’s hometown,
in fact he’s Lan Mandragoran,
heir to the throne of a kingdom
that was lost to The Blight many years ago.
Lan is the strong silent type,
and Nynaeve’s the standoffish type,
so these two get it on!
By the way, Rand and Egwene
are a longstanding couple,
but they've been separated
this whole time,
and now they fight over nothing
because Rand’s kind of whiny.
But he apologizes and they
get back together, they’re in love.
But now Moiraine gives
the kids the bad news,
At The Dark One’s prison, whoever
is not The Dragon, will 100% die.
So Moiraine visits a bartender here
named Min who can read people's futures
in hopes that she can tell
which one is The Dragon.
She says she can't tell, but later,
while Rand is doing some late
night archery, he has an epiphany...
This whole time he's been channeling
the One Power without realizing!
So he goes to see Min, who’s like
“Yeah kid, I know you, I saw your birth.”
There's a race of desert warrior
people called the Aiel,
who all have pale skin and red hair
- like you do in the desert.
This Aiel warrior was fighting
super pregnant,
and oh, the baby's coming right now!
She was found by one of
the enemy soldiers,
yeah that's Rand’s shepherd dad,
Tam al’Thor
His mom died in childbirth, so he
took Rand home to raise as his own.
“So wait, does that mean I'm The Dragon?”
“Yeah? I don't know, I-- probably.”
So to save his friends he grabs Moiriane,
and the two of them go off alone
to venture through the Blight.
But now that Rand’s close, he gets a
dream visit from The Dark One himself...
who's like, “Hey, man,
I'm actually just a normal dude.”
It's like “Hey, Dragon,
good to see you again.”
But he’s pretty disappointed Rand
doesn't remember his past life.
But we get to see a brief flashback to
3000 years ago, at the end of the last Age,
when the world was like a
super advanced, magical utopia.
And The Dragon was this guy, Lews Therin,
who was a male Aes Sedai,
yeah back then the male part of
The Power wasn't corrupted.
Apparently him sealing The Dark One
is what corrupted it, and then “broke the world”.
And so we come to the Dark One’s
prison at the Eye of the World.
He seal’s weak enough that he
can manifest here,
Moiraine tries to fight him
but he's way too strong,
Stills her immediately,
cuts her off from Magic!
Rand falls into a vision coma, where he
and Egwene are living a happy simple life.
The Dark One’s like, “Yeah man,
this can be real...”
“all you have to do is free me.”
Meanwhile, The Dark One’s Trollocs
are invading Fal Dara,
And long story short,
the army is totally wrecked.
So it's up to the king’s sister who's an Aes Sedai,
and gathers up Egwene and Nynaeve
and any women who can channel, and
they all work together to do a big spell
that Blam! Destroys the whole army!
But there's a good reason
they didn't lead with that,
because channeling that much power
burns you up and kills you.
But Nynaeve is somehow able to take
Egwene’s share of the Power herself,
to save Egwene, and Nynaeve dies!
Over in dreamland, Rand looks like
he’s going to take The Dark One’s deal,
But wait, what's this?
“Sike, bro!”
“Yeah I'm going to put you back
in your prison,” and the day is... saved?
But the physical seal is all cracked now,
which sure doesn't seem like
it was strengthened...
And back at the fort, they were pulling
their magic item out of storage
When oh, they’re all killed!
By none other than...
Padan Fain, the peddler
from the beginning!
Yes, he's a Dark Friend who's been
following them this whole time,
And he's like “Yeah, this ain't over,
we're just getting started...”
“This series was 14 books.”
So as season 1 comes to an end,
Perrin grabs an axe,
but he's committed now to the
nonviolent Way of the Leaf.
And on his way out Padan Fain grabbed
Matt's cursed dagger! So watch out for that.
Matt himself is just chillin back in the city,
but the actor's been recast,
so he'll look different.
Egwene is mourning Nynaeve’s death,
but oh, she manages to heal her somehow!
So actually Nynaeve’s fine.
And Rand al’Thor, the Dragon Reborn,
He's like “Wait, now that I channeled
magic, am I going to go crazy?”
And Moiraine’s like
“Yeah, I mean, probably.”
So to save his friends from himself,
he's like “Tell them I died here.”
And Rand's going off on his own!
To just... be on his own.
And there's a final teaser
on the other side of the continent
that's now facing an invasion
from a mysterious power across the sea!
They use channelers in warfare
to make a big tidal wave,
And that's where Wheel of Time
season one comes to an end.
If you liked this Recap,
hit that subscribe button,
or more of the best Recaps
of TV and movies.